In the wave of Disney's live-action remakes,
one just might end up taking the cake when
it comes to critical success and audience
enjoyment.
Yup, we're talking about Mulan a live-action
reimagining of the 1999 smash hit.
This is everything you need to know about
the upcoming take on the beloved Disney classic.
Audiences will have to wait until March 27,
2020 for Mulan's triumphant return to theaters
just over two decades after the original film's
release date in June of 1998.
The 2020 release date isn't surprising, as
Disney already packed 2019 with remakes and
revivals of animated properties Dumbo, Aladdin,
The Lion King, Maleficent: Mistress of Evil,
and Lady and the Tramp.
With so many live-action films coming out
at once, it's nice that we'll get a little
bit of a breather before Mulan takes the stage.
After all, it would be a shame for the film
to lose some luster simply because audiences
are suffering from live-action remake fatigue.
One thing that's a bit surprising is the fact
that, while never on the docket for a 2019
release date, Mulan was actually originally
slated to hit the big screen before any of
the aforementioned titles.
Once upon a time, the remake was supposed
to be released on November 2, 2018.
Why shift the date by nearly a year and a
half?
Because it took over a year to find the right
actress to play the lead role.
Once that was done, the film was locked into
the March 27th slot, and it looks like it'll
be making the rescheduled date without any
issues.
So, how did the casting process end up pushing
the Mulan remake back by over a year?
It turns out that finding the perfect person
to play the lead role wasn't just challenging
it was about as difficult a task as possible.
According to The Hollywood Reporter, Disney
enlisted a team of casting directors that
visited five continents, where they saw nearly
1,000 different candidates audition for the
role.
Talk about doing your homework.
It makes sense, though, as you don't meet
a girl like this every dynasty.
The casting team wasn't just looking for actresses
who had passable martial arts skills and could
speak English fluently.
They also made a top priority out of finding
someone who was ethnically Chinese, as well.
After spending such a gargantuan amount of
time and effort, the team finally chose the
popular Chinese American actress Liu Yifei.
The choice was a near-perfect one Liu Yifei
is talented and has already proven her acting
chops.
Along with a string of other projects, the
actress has starred in The Forbidden Kingdom
and Outcast, both of which saw her holding
her own alongside well-established actors
like Jackie Chan, Nicolas Cage, and Jet Li.
"I will bring honor to us all."
Having worked alongside him on 2008's The
Forbidden Kingdom, Liu Yifei is reteaming
with Jet Li for Mulan.
The martial arts master has been tapped to
play the venerable Emperor of China.
This is exciting news, even if it's a fairly
reserved role all things considered here's
hoping they can sneak him into a fight sequence
alongside the titular character.
In addition to Li, the film has cast Mulan's
slapstick trio of fellow warriors Yao, Ling,
and Chien Po . Ling will be played by Jimmy
Wong, Po by Doua Moua, and Chen Tang will
be taking up the role of Yao, the so-called
"king of the rock."
One significant face missing from the action,
though?
Li Shang.
The hunky commander has failed to show up
on any casting reports so far.
Instead, it looks like the production team
has opted to split Shang's prominent character
into two separate personalities.
Donnie Yen has been cast as the character
Commander Tung, who appears to be taking on
the role of Mulan's military commander.
Separate from that relationship, we have Chen
Honghui, played by Yoson An.
It appears that Chen Hongui will be a fellow
recruit in Tung's unit who bonds with Mulan
before the two form a romantic relationship.
Of course, even the best cast isn't going
to get very far without a good group of people
working behind the scenes as well.
Fortunately, the story of China's warrior-heroine
appears to be in good hands.
Starting at the top, Disney has tapped Niki
Caro to helm the project.
The Kiwi director has already drawn attention
thanks to her work on films like North Country,
The Zookeeper's Wife, and McFarland, USA.
She first established herself in 2002 with
Whale Rider, a Maori film with feminist themes
of family, destiny, and generational divides
some obvious parallels with Mulan.
For all of her past accomplishments, though,
a blockbuster like Mulan could launch Caro
to new heights.
In fact, the simple act of taking the job
made her the fourth woman to ever solo-direct
a film with a $100 million+ budget.
If she manages to knock the project out of
the park, then the sky's the limit.
Along with Caro, a team of four writers has
been brought on to adapt the story to a live-action
format.
They include Rick Jaffa, Amanda Silver, Elizabeth
Martin, and Lauren Hynek.
Jaffa and Silver are of particular interest,
as they have worked together on both Jurassic
World and the recent Planet of the Apes films.
This gives them plenty of experience in bringing
classic stories into the modern era, which
is encouraging, to say the least.
Before we get too far into the possible direction
that the live-action remake could take, let's
take a quick trip down memory lane and revisit
just how Disney's 1998 animated version of
Mulan played out.
The film takes place in ancient China, during
the Han Dynasty.
In response to a Hun invasion, the Emperor
orders a full mobilization, including one
man from every family.
This prompts Mulan to buck tradition and go
in her aged father's stead, disguised as a
young man.
She is soon joined by the disgraced family
guardian, a tiny dragon named Mushu, and the
two manage to convince everyone that she can
bring the goods.
After training with the other recruits, Mulan's
unit sets out to reinforce the imperial army,
only to find that they've already been annihilated
by the deadly Huns.
Mulan heroically saves her brothers in arms
and, y'know, the whole of China by causing
an avalanche to sweep away the enemy during
an ambush.
In the process, though, she is revealed to
be a woman and is cast out of the army.
Finding that some of the Huns, including their
leader Shan Yu, have survived the avalanche,
Mulan fearlessly follows the soldiers to the
imperial city, where she alerts everyone to
the approach of the Huns and helps foil their
attempt to kill the Emperor.
Ultimately, Mulan is recognized for her heroic
deeds, and returns home to celebrations and
a visit from her commander Shang, whom she
invites to stay forever — uh, we mean, for
dinner.
"Would you like to stay for dinner?"
"Would you like to stay forever?"
"Dinner would be great."
While the live-action remake will obviously
be leaning heavily on the '90s animated classic
for the bulk of its inspiration, there's also
the original Chinese legend itself which the
writers can draw from and based on the gritty
realism depicted in the trailer so far, it
looks like they're doing just that.
Of course, old stories like these almost always
have a ton of different versions over the
centuries.
Naturally, this means the exact details of
the legend have varied over the years.
That said, Mulan's traditional story takes
place in ancient China during either the 4th
or 5th century.
There are many distinctly similar factors
that modern audiences will recognize in the
tale as well.
For instance, the story always starts with
a horde of barbarians invading China.
This leads to Mulan volunteering to enlist
as her aged father's "son" in order to save
him from having to go to war, where he'll
meet almost certain death.
She takes her family's heirloom weapons, joins
up with the army, and finds success as a soldier.
She even falls in love with an officer and
is offered a reward from the Emperor, at which
point she simply asks for a horse to ride
home.
For all of the similarities across versions
of the story, there are also many things that
are completely different.
For example, while the animated feature manages
to neatly fit everything into what feels like
a few weeks or possibly months, Mulan actually
fought in the ranks as a warrior for a decade.
We're talking about a legitimate army career
here.
Not only that, but she was eventually promoted
to general status.
At one point, some stories explain that she
goes into battle dressed as a woman with the
specific intention of inspiring her men by
revealing her true identity.
It works, and her soldiers gain an even greater
respect for her.
While Mulan does eventually draw the attention
of the Emperor, it's not quite as epic as
the climactic finale of the '90s movie.
Rather, the Emperor simply finds out that
his bravest soldier is a woman and, impressed,
offers her a reward.
She asks for a horse and rides home, only
to find that her father has died during her
long absence at least in some versions of
the story.
This tragic ending gets even worse in some
accounts, as she is forced to become the wife
or concubine of an emperor.
In the end, refusing to accept this fate,
China's greatest heroine ultimately takes
her own life.
While he didn't have a ton of lines, Shan
Yu was a pretty important character in the
original animated film, and it wasn't until
Mulan literally lit the man up over the imperial
city that everyone could breathe a collective
sigh of relief.
Despite his importance, though, it appears
that the writers have actually decided to
ax the big bad from the remake.
Instead, the production team is cashing in
on a little creative liberty and going in
a different if still quite intimidating direction.
The film has brought in Gong Li, known for
her role in Memoirs of a Geisha, to play the
powerful witch Xian Lang.
The official trailer also sets up another
villain, the warlord Bori Khan, but it appears
he will be little more than a frontman for
Lang's nefarious plans.
This shift from brute force to the supernatural
is a curious one, and it'll be interesting
to see how it plays out on the big screen.
A trailer also makes a deliberate attempt
to compare Mulan to a phoenix which traditionally
sits at the right hand of the emperor and
is his guardian and his protector while also
showing the witch literally turning into a
bird of prey, indicating a fowl showdown of
some sort or another is afoot.
On top of that, one of the trailers even showcases
a duel between the two female warriors.
Of course, what would a Mulan remake be without
the guardian of lost souls?
The Eddie Murphy-voiced Mushu is one of the
most fondly-remembered elements of the original
animated classic.
"You da man!
...Well, sort of."
Mushu superfans should be careful before they
get their hopes too high when it comes to
the remake, though.
While the fan blog DisInsider did report that
a source had claimed the little guy would
be in the film, very little information has
come out about what his actual role would
be.
Will we see the powerful, the pleasurable,
the indestructible Mushu?
Or will we see a live-action alternative that
is more subdued and subtle?
Maybe we won't get an actual character at
all, but merely a quick glimpse of a small
dragon statue or some other Easter egg.
So far, no one is reported to have been cast
in the role, which doesn't bode well for a
direct adaptation from the '90s original.
However, fans can take comfort in the fact
that the cast list does contain an entry for
a character named Cricket, which hints that
perhaps Mushu's sidekick Cri-Kee will somehow
be represented.
The official trailer seems to heavily imply
that the story will be steering into the "Mulan,
the phoenix" angle pretty hard.
It even cuts to a shot of a live phoenix while
Mulan's father is asking the ancestors to
protect her.
Perhaps instead of having no protector, we'll
simply be seeing Mushu swapped out for a more
appropriately epic phoenix guardian.
Check out one of our newest videos right here!
Plus, even more Looper videos about your favorite
stuff are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit the
bell so you don't miss a single one.